la plupart des flâneurs du square
dorchester l'ignorent mais il marche sur
un cimetière catholique du 19e siècle
qui s'étend aussi sous la place du
canada au sud quand je leur dis que
peut-être encore quarante à cinquante
mille sépultures en classe
ils sont complètement
étonné depuis quelques semaines les
travaux de réfection de la place du
canada ont commencé mais pas question de
creuser sans protéger le cimetière saint
antoine où des milliers de catholiques
ont été enterrés de 1799 à 1854 à la fin
de cette période on avait commencé à
déménager les morts sur la montagne
mais finalement les risques sanitaires
liés à l'inhumation ont stoppé le
mouvement et le centre ville s'est
développée sur l'ancien cimetière c'est
toute la russie
ce toute la place du canada la rue peel
de l'autre côté rené lévesque passe
d'abord le score dans chastain les
archéologues de la ville de montréal
s'assure que ce patrimoine sera préservé
parce qu'on a travaillé avec les
architectes les ingénieurs pour faire en
sorte de construire les places un peu un
ensemble de façon à préserver le
sénateur un sous sol jusqu'à maintenant
c'est une centaine de sépultures dont 20
complète qui devront être déplacés pour
ne pas être endommagées par les travaux
les restes humains qui seront
recueillies vont être étudiées puis
enterré au cimetière notre dame des
neiges dans un emplacement prévu pour
eux ces morts vont nous apprendre bien
des choses
les gars nous révèle beaucoup de choses
aussi sur les carences alimentaires mais
aussi sur la provenance de certains
individus
c'est très très rare au québec on ne
peut de ce matière qu'on peut fouiller
les archéologues sont souvent impliqués
dans les grands projets de construction
c'est le cas aussi à l'île des soeurs où
passera le nouveau pont sur le
saint-laurent puisque le sol cachent les
restes de la ferme le berre datant de la
fin du régime français
la construction du nouveau pont
champlain est une opportunité qu'on n'a
pas manqué pour remettre balas et ces
artefacts là qui sont là depuis six ans
quelque chose mais que personne loi
infrastructure canada s'assure que tout
ce qui a une valeur patrimoniale sera
récupéré et mis en valeur
ailleurs les fouilles doivent commencer
à l'automne un aspect de montréal qu'on
connaît très peu
même que je me rends compte qu'avec mes
étudiants la plupart ne savent même pas
qu'ils aient de l'archéologie qui se
fait à montréal alors que le centre
ville fourmille de vie en surface les
morts vont continuer à reposer en paix
dans l'anonymat mais il y aura des
indices de leur présence sur la nouvelle
place du canada comme c'est le cas ici
déjà au square dorchester ici anne
louise despatie radio canada montréal